Samsung vient de sortir son smartphone
qui va cartonner cette année c'est le
Galaxy A54 5G vous avez un grand écran
Super AMOLED de 6,4 pouces avec un taux
de rafraîchissement de sa mère vous
pourrez faire tourner plein de jeux du
Play Store l'expérience va être
extrêmement fluide vous avez une grosse
batterie de 5000 milliampères heure et
la charge rapide 25 watts vous avez 4
générations de mise à jour Android et 5
ans mise à jour de sécurité et vous
pouvez voir sur les photos le rendu est
qualitatif sur le grand-angle ça marche
bien ultra grand-angle et pas mal la
macro par contre bon c'est un peu en
dessous c'est un smartphone qui a un
design irrité des galaxies S23 donc le
plus haut de gamme aujourd'hui c'est
smartphone se ressemblent et ça va être
difficile pour un non initié de venir
différencier un Galaxy S23 d'un Galaxy
a53 vous avez du wifi 6 vous avez une
SIM vous avez un Corning Gorillaz 5 au
dos celui Galaxy A54 est disponible au
tarif de 499 € dans la version 8 Go de
RAM 128 Go de stockage et 549 euros dans
la version 8 Go de RAM 256 Go de
stockage je vous en ai fait une vidéo
complète sur Youtube vous saurez tout
aller jeter un petit coup d'oeil
personnellement je l'aime beaucoup je
trouve très très bien d'ailleurs
dites-moi ce que vous en pensez ce qui
peut vous intéresser oui non pas comment
vous marrer tout ça en bas dans les
commentaires